just as the sun will come out tomorrow
so too can we count on those magnificent
beefcake boys
and gearhead girls in the fast and the
furious franchise to arrive
with another action-packed installment
from a focus on family to celebrity
cameos
here are the things that happen in every
single fast and the furious movie
while fast five and fast and furious six
cemented
family as a highly memeable character
motivation for vin diesel's dominic
toretto family has always been the third
most important
f word of the franchise right behind
fast and furious
after all the first film is about a
loner cop finding a community
in dom's dvd player stealing crew and
the sequel is about paul walker's brian
trying to mend fences with his childhood
best friend roman
in a story that wouldn't play out any
differently if they were
actually related by blood tokyo drift is
about carving out a place for yourself
apart from a familial legacy you might
not have wanted
and the fourth film is about what
happens when a member of your family is
murdered
you go on a street racing rampage in
short long before dom looked right at
the camera and told audiences around the
world
i don't have friends i got family
fast and the furious has always been
about the family connections we make for
ourselves
the fast and the furious franchise as it
stands today feels more like a james
bond spin-off series than the adventures
of a bunch of street racing dirtbags
that we started with
still even as the stakes have gotten
higher and dom's family has gotten
bigger
a major constant in the franchise is
that most problems can be solved with
fast cars
it might seem silly to point this out
after all one of the two major
adjectives in the franchise's title is
related to speed
but considering how massive the set
pieces have become it's comforting that
the main solution to
any problem has always been fast cars
driving where you wouldn't expect
cars to drive whether it's destroying
the entire police force of rio de
janeiro and fast five or taking out a
nuclear submarine in russia with the use
of an american muscle car
there's no problem in the fast and the
furious world that can't be solved by
living your life
one quarter mile at a time starts out
stealing dvd players in east l.a
ends up heisting a hundred million
dollars in rio
not bad huh considering the utility of a
properly engineered vehicle in the fast
and the furious franchise
it's no surprise that the crew takes
some time to appreciate their fleet of
their vehicles
whenever they can the fast family are a
bunch of gear heads at heart
and that means their cars aren't just
tools for super spy adventures
the cars are a reflection of themselves
before the franchise became as action
driven as it is today
the cars were arguably the biggest draw
of the early films and that aesthetic
appreciation remains a core driver in
the franchise
no matter how high the stakes are
there's always time for the characters
to pause
and admire the cars they'll be driving
in upcoming scenes
that moment arguably reaches its peak in
fate of the furious
when little nobody takes the fast family
into a secret government warehouse
full of confiscated vehicles they can
use to rescue dom
just because the world is at stake
doesn't mean we can't take some time to
peek under the hood
here's something you might not have
noticed no good guy
in the fast and the furious franchise
has ever lost
a fight if that feels surprising think
about some of the greatest smackdowns in
the films
there's dom fighting hobbs in a garage
during fast five hobbs fighting shaw
early and furious 7 or
dom fighting literally every other
member of his family in fate of the
furious
but these impressive battles don't just
belong to the beefcakes
brian somehow manages to beat kiet in
furious 7
despite the fact the bad guy is played
by real-life thai martial artist
tony jaw most fights in the fast and the
furious universe either end with the
good guy walking away the clear victor
or the fight itself being interrupted by
circumstances
outside of the hero's control with
regards to that hobbes and shaw
smackdown
the fight only ends when hobbes is
knocked out of a window by an explosion
while covering for elena
when it comes to the hobbs and dom
slugfest it gets interrupted before an
unquestionable victor can be crowned
as a result there are rumors of a can't
lose contract for some of the actors but
whether or not
that's true the fact remains that if
you're a good guy in the world of fast
and the furious
no weapon raised against you will
prosper even comic relief roman gets a
moment in fate of the furious where he
knocks a guy off a snowmobile with a car
door before shooting three other
faceless goons the fast and the furious
franchise has earned a bit of a
reputation for being needlessly complex
which isn't really fair after all the
order of the films
are simple if you want to watch it
chronologically you just watch the fast
and the furious
the short film turbocharged prelude to
too fast too furious
too fast too furious the short film los
bandelleros
fast and furious fast five fast and
furious six
until the post credits scene then watch
half of fast and furious tokyo drift
after that take a break for sure then
watch the post credits to fast and
furious 6
watch most of the rest of fast and
furious tokyo drift
watch furious 7 until dom wants to go to
tokyo
then finish watching the very end of
fast and furious tokyo drift
before completing furious 7 and enjoying
fate of the furious
oh and watch better luck tomorrow if
you're a completionist and want to see
the origin of han
simple right okay maybe the franchise
has gotten
pretty complex but that's what happens
when you keep building on the continuity
without writing characters off between
films
each installment showcases either the
appearance of an old character
or at least a off mentioned to previous
films it can take the form of brian
investigating fast and furious villain
braga midway through fast and furious 6
or dom relying on his fast 5 crew and
fate of the furious
but no matter who shows up or when you
can always count on some familiar faces
to pop up
in a fast and furious film with each
new fast and the furious film's budget
ballooning into the hundreds of
millions it's no stretch to say the
movies are known for their jaw-dropping
action but even when the budget was in
the sub-100 million range
the filmmakers still found a way to pack
plenty of action into the films
the fast and the furious features a
climax in which one of dom's men is
wired tight to a semi-truck while the
driver shoots a shotgun at dom's crew
meanwhile too fast too furious ends with
roman and brian
launching a car onto a boat like someone
trying to weaponize the dukes of hazard
boys
and tokyo drift finds han and the
ostensible protagonist sean boswell
drifting through the tokyo streets as
crowds of people part
like the red sea by the time fast five
rolls around
the films have gotten so big that brian
and dom are destroying
rio with a vault that they're using like
a wrecking ball
there's no telling what insane set
pieces we can expect in the future
but if there's anything that lives up to
dom leaping across a bridge from his car
to save leddy from getting knocked off a
tank
we can all die happy at its core
the first fast and the furious film is a
movie with
simple pleasures in mind there are cars
and they will go fast
there are tough guys and they will win
fights there are beautiful girls in
bikinis that are
big fans of both cars and tough guys and
they will dance even as the films have
rounded out the cast those core ideals
remain the same
no matter what destinations the fast
family visit there's always going to be
time for a race and there are always
going to be
beautiful women that are excited to
watch even while dom was working to
restore letty's memory in fast and
furious 6
there was a london street race that
featured plenty of car girls
it might be one of the strongest
connective tissues uniting the various
locales in the franchise
a signifier of car culture that
surpasses any sort of division or
geographical line
or most likely it's because the fast and
the furious directors like shooting
scenes with gorgeous women in exotic
locales
it's not all seriousness and widescreen
action when you're part of dom's crew
sure
there's a chance that you'll be blown up
by a former sas operative or that you'll
fall
onto an endless airplane runway in the
middle of a gun battle
but there are good times too after all
dom knows how to throw a killer party
even if the beer selection is limited
you can have any brew you want
as long as it's a corona every film in
the fast and the furious franchise has
made time for a party
whether it's the now traditional
post-action barbecue or the low-budget
house party of the fast and the furious
even furious 7 grim as everything was in
the wake of han's untimely murder
still found time to have a party dj'd by
t-pain in abu dhabi
when you live your life one quarter mile
at a time you've got to leave room to
celebrate
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the fast saga are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one